المسيره الامريكيه كانت قد تحطمت بعد
اصطدامها بمقاتله روسيه فوق البحر الاسود
وبحسب الجيش الامريكي حاول الطائرتان
روسيتان اعتراض الطائره المسيره الامريكيه
مع ايقاف تشغيل اجهزه الارسال والاستقبال
الخاصه بها
الحادث وقع في حوالي الساعه السابعه
بتوقيت وسط اوروبا واستمر ما بين ثلاثين
الى اربعين دقيقه حسب الجيش الامريكي
وقد تحطمت الطائره المسيره بعد مناوره
حاده مع فقدانها تماما وقد نفت روسيا حدوث
اي تلامس مع طائره روسيه ما تسبب في سقوط
المسيره
ولعده مرات قبل الاصطدام القت مقاتلتان
روسيتان من طراز سخوي 27 الوقود نحو
الطائره المسيره بطريقه متهوره وغير سليمه
بيئيا ومهنيا وفق الجيش الامريكي
ومن ثم صدمت احدى المقاتلتين الروسيتين
مروحه هذه المسيره وهو مضطر القوات
الامريكيه الى اسقاطها في المياه الدوليه